hi my name is Viper and today we will
learn about functions so functions are a
very important concept both for your
engineering entrance exams and also in
order to understand various concepts in
mathematics it's a very fundamental
concept and it is used to describe a lot
of phenomena in both the physical
chemical and other other phenomenon that
happens in the real world so and also a
lot of a lot of chapters that you will
learn further on such as like limits
derivatives continuity and like be it
any other chapter in mathematics here
knowing functions is very important so
it's a very fundamental chapter it has
various definitions and a lot of use for
the next topics that you learn so we'll
start with a with an intuitive
definition of functions something which
use which will try to understand using
examples and then we will try to go into
a more mathematically precise definition
so functions are used to describe a
special relation
between two variables so here the world
relation is a mathematical concept that
will understand later but this is a very
intuitive concept where like what we are
trying to see is we have two variables
of interest and we are trying to define
the what is the relationship between
them and that that is something which is
important in a lot of places because you
always have something such as an input
to a system and an output to a system
and you want to figure out what the
system is doing and functions come in
handy at that place a lot so and so this
is a very intuitive sort of description
of functions and in order to define it
using for our use we took like
mathematicians use different types of
descriptors for functions and typically
functions are described
using a graph
I'd rule or an equation and now we will
see like how the system so when you have
two variables either you can draw a
graph draw a plot to show how they are
related or you can have a very intuitive
rule which you can very easily describe
or at times like as we will see in more
and more will be using equations to
describe a function so let's begin with
a very simple example we'll take a life
of a typical student who is studying for
who's studying for an exam and going to
school and we want to figure out how how
his or her day goes so let's call that
student so know and we want to find out
how so new statement and the variable
that we are interested in is how far so
know is from home so variable one and
that will predict this time and variable
two will be so knows distance
from home now let's go to our first
definition that we wrote
so first description for function this
function is a special relation between
two variables and here what we have are
two variables of interest one is time of
the day and how far Stoneham is from his
own so let's let's try to make a plot
for like a typical day I'll try to
remember how my school days were and try
to make a plot based on that so so I'll
just divide so on x-axis
I'll draw time of day and on y-axis I
will draw a distance from home
so we will count time from midnight so 0
and in 24-hour format so 0 then let's
say 5 10 15 20 and 24 because the day
has 24 hours and then we want to figure
out how the day went so in morning sono
was at home till 6 o clock then he went
went to school so the distance was some
distance how how much fire the school
was and then he was at school to roughly
2 p.m. which is 14 hours then he went to
a friend then let's say he goes to a
friend's place spend some time there and
then comes back at to home and then
spends the rest of the time at home so
here we see that very intuitively we can
describe relationship between two
variables using a plot and this plot
essentially is describing a function of
where the rail zone is throughout the
day like how far Sonam is from his home
throughout the day with respect to the
time of the day so similarly we can draw
such graphs or such relations for
different variables so taking an example
from physics let's say we want to study
a similar thing but for a object which
is moving with a constant velocity so
let's take another example
and if you want to draw a plot of the
distance of this object from the
starting point it will be something very
similar to this the nature of the graph
will be different but essentially we are
plotting similar things
so again variable one will be time and
variable two will be distance from start
and we know if an object is moving with
the constant velocity it can be
described by an equation which is let's
say we'd describe variable two using the
variable D and this is described by T so
D will be equal to and let's say the
speed is one which is given so one times
T where T is in hours so now this is an
example where we describe the function
with an equation so we saw that a
function can be described by a graph a
rule so at first the rule was where you
are from home or it could be a rule like
object moving with constant speed and
then at time so you also use equations
and they are interchangeable so here we
can write this rule as an equation and
this equation as a graph so let me try
to draw a straight line and this is how
how the distance varies with time so
these are some examples of functions
which occur in like day to day
activities and in these examples we see
that the functions input is the variable
one was always time in both of these
example but that doesn't have to be the
case functions can have different with
different notions of variable one and
variable two depending on the
application another interesting way to
look at functions is as an input-output
relation so here in in the
examples that we studied we had two
variables and we can also think of them
as a relation between input function
which goes through a function and out
comes output so in example 1 input was
time of day and output was distance from
home
similarly an example to the input was
time in hours and output was distance
from starting location so we have seen
multiple ways of intuitively describing
the function so either it could be a
special type of relation between two
variables which could be described using
a graph rule or equation
it could be thing thought of as a system
which converts an input to an output and
that is and whenever we have something
anything of this sort we can use
functions to describe them now once we
have these functions like there they are
very useful and they can be they can be
manually manipulated to figure out a lot
of properties of the system so so far we
have seen like a few examples now I
would request you to take some time to
think about other functions that you
encounter in daily life so for those of
you who like sports you can think of
something let's say in cricket your
favorite batsman hits a ball and you
want to figure out how fast the ball is
moving so you can have time after which
the ball was hit and the speed of the
ball and it doesn't have to be anything
to do with speed or time it could be
something altogether different so let's
say you are traveling in a train from
Bombay to Delhi and at Mumbai 20 people
ride on the train and then the number of
people changes every station and based
on the distance from Mumbai you can
figure out the number of passengers in
the train so in in this example in the
train example so distance is the input
variable or variable one distance from
start and output variable is number of
passengers
and similarly you can make other for
other functions you can find other
functions in your day-to-day activities
and they they occur in like almost all
physical and in various physical and
chemical phenomenon and so a lot of
things that you are learning in physics
and chemistry are also typical so like
functions are also used for their to
describe this phenomenon so like yeah
again takes some time to think about
examples of functions and also one thing
that that is very important to see here
is what makes variable one go on the x
axis and variable y go on the Y so is it
possible to flip time and distance from
home in this in this graph so think
think about Y variable when one is on
x-axis and variable two is on Y axis one
way to reason you could think of as
variable one is sort of input and
variable two is output but there are
other reasons as we will see as we go
ahead so this was a very intuitive
definition of functions now let's try to
see it from a mathematical
mathematically precise perspective so
for that we'll go back to our original
statement that functions are used to
describe a special relation between two
variables so here we have like a few
mathematical terms we have relations and
we have variables and we will try to see
how how they relate to the mathematical
concepts that we already know so one
thing that you have already learned is
sets sets are a collection of items and
so let's say we have a set a and B where
a could be like any any object of
interest and B could be another set of
object of interest and let's say we
denote elements of a by a small a and
elements of B by small V so once we have
this set we have variables from these
sets and we can use and whenever there
is any relationship between these
variables we can define them using
certain mathematical constructs
so one construct is a Cartesian product
of two sets
so a Cartesian product of two sets a B
is given by a cross P and includes all
the elements a comma B so let's say if
set a has two variables let's say a 1
and a 2 and set B has one variable B 1
then a cross B will have three variables
because a 1 comma B 1 a 2 comma B 1 and
oh sorry it will have two variables as
well but if set we had another variable
B 2 then the additional variables will
be 4 so a 1 comma B 1 B 2 and a 2 comma
B 2 so Cartesian product of two sets
essentially includes number of elements
from set a x number of elements from set
B and this is a very big set and a
relation is defined as a subset of the
Cartesian product so let's say for some
reason you are only interested in a
subset of this this Cartesian product
set we let's say call it by R so this R
let's say has a 1 comma B 1 and a 2
comma B 2 and so this is any subset of
the Cartesian product is it's a relation
so now we have defined some of the
quantities that we needed to know in
order to sort of understand our
intuitive definition of functions and
now that we have defined like the
important concepts that we need to
define our precise definition of
functions we'll see in the next lecture
how we combine sets Cartesian products
and relations specifically relations to
figure out what is special about
functions